Sorry to bother you. I'm a
Big fan of Heather's
you're her assistant right? yeah
I just, I had to come up and say hello
Heather how's the love life. I've got nothing to tell you stan
Do you have alcohol at your place?
Why are we here? You've a gun right?
Feel like there's so many crazy people who are mad at me right now
You know how to shoot a gun? How many movies have I shotguns in -? Two.
You know how you were saying you don't feel safe. I feel like that all the time
(screams)
I felt like you're feeling right now, usually why it's so tough for me to ask you what I've got to ask you.
What do you have to ask me?
You remember things am I right I?
I think you might remember things more than most people
Think back, what is the last thing you saw in this house?
Did she ever threaten you or -- no she's didn't threaten me. Cause' I've heard stories about movie stars
Am I under arrest? Not yet.
Motive. Opportunity. Capacity. until we're like freaking best friend and collect that kill each other all the time
Are you following me?
I'm asking you to be careful
You might not think something's important and then - bingo it's the key to the whole thing